it's very undesirable Oscar Vasquez has
owned his Miami beach condo for more
than 25 years and says he's never seen
this much sarcasm a seaweed this early
there are parts of the beach where it's
undesirable and difficult to get into
the water
specialized tractors have been raking up
the clumps of brown weeds that line
these beaches but by the time the sun
rises again
they're usually back the sargasm that is
picked up is destined for landfills but
before it's piled just offshore
releasing a foul odor not to be overly
dramatic I feel that maybe I bought in
the wrong place really
yeah because this is not what I
bargained for the seaweed is naturally
occurring but this year scientists say
there's a bumper crop